>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Music ]
>> Katherine Blood: So it is the
Asamblea de Artistas Revolucionarios
de Oaxaca and they go by the acronym
ASARO and they sign as a collective
and this is partly as a way
to weigh the size of this.
So, this is partly as a way
to be in solidarity together
but it is also a safety measure
because this group began during
the teacher uprisings in 2006.
I am going to lay it down.
It is a little difficult to--
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Yes,
you want to crumble it up.
>> Katherine Blood:
But they are very fresh
so these began during the uprisings
in 2006 and the artists signed
as a collective partly
as a safety measure
to keep some individual anonymity.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Oh that's right.
>> Katherine Blood: But the
images are very powerful.
They were meant to be
shown on the streets.
They were meant to bring attention
to any number of different issues
that were important to the artists.
So, artist's responses to an array
of different social
and political subjects.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And then,
so you are right this takes place
in Oaxaca and just like in the
other examples these are artists
that are saying something
to the public at large.
And Oaxaca has a lot of art
recently that has been coming out.
>> Katherine Blood: Absolutely.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And
I just meant some artists in,
a great group of artists, the
Oaxaca, the Oaxacanos, in Seattle.
There's a great group
of artists in Seattle
and here we see doing a similar kind
of work but this is very different.
And I am so glad to hear this.
And we are going to also perhaps
feature some of this work by ASARO--
>> Katherine Blood: ASARO
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
ASARO Asamblea
>> Katherine Blood: Asamblea de
Artistas Revolucionarios de Oaxaca,
so thankfully they're called
very concisely by ASARO.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: ASARO.
>> Katherine Blood: Can we talk a
little bit about the imagery here?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Sure
let's talk about the imagery.
>> Katherine Blood: It is
really interesting in terms
of visual literacy because
it is a very poetic image.
It is not a literal image.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That's right.
>> Katherine Blood: And you sort
of have to spend time with it
and read it just the way you
would read a poem or a book.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: That's true.
So, there's kind of like an
[foreign word] a close line,
or it could be a rail,
or it could be a rainbow.
>> Katherine Blood: I
thought a [foreign word].
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: A --
[ Foreign Language ]
Right. And there's the eyes and
there's a woman's face looking down
and she's very sad, serious,
troubled, solemn, in pain perhaps.
And then there's a three
more [foreign word] hanging
and flowing in the wind or rain.
And they are images of?
>> Katherine Blood: Angels.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Angels.
>> Katherine Blood: Three angels.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And
there are two hands shooting
out of the earth or the darkness
and they are- What are they doing?
>> Katherine Blood: It looks very,
it's an ambivalent image to me
because they look very vital
and they are reaching to the sky
but the figure is essentially
buried.
And so you have all of these
clues that lead you to the idea
that this is maybe a
memorial or a mourning image.
Although, there's, it's not titled.
It's not dated but we know it's from
around 2006 to 2009 so we know when
and where it was made and by whom.
And we have these clues but you
can interpret it different ways.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That's right.
And even the buried
figure remains vital.
>> Katherine Blood: And
the cacti and the mountains
and the rain also shooting stars,
you know, so lots of different --
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And
the artwork is also vibrating.
>> Katherine Blood: Absolutely.
It is really robust, this carving.
Yes. I mean it is a
very classical image.
We have images by Elizabeth Catlin
that are celebrating the laborer,
the worker, the farmer, and the
title here they have given us some
from text you see very prominent
front and center dignidad --
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Dignidad.
>> Katherine Blood: Dignity.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Dignity.
>> Katherine Blood:
And then smaller--
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
And smaller hidden figures
which say [foreign word].
>> Katherine Blood: Yea.
>> Struggle, fight
and what are those?
Are those the corn?
>> Katherine Blood: Maiz.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Maiz kind
of has a sense of being a grenade.
>> Katherine Blood: It's true.
They almost look like, yes
so it is a power image.
They almost look like weapons.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Like weapons.
>> Katherine Blood: Yes, it's true.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Yea.
>> But every person can come
to these images and sort
of get something different
from them.
And we know a little bit about, we
know a lot about the artist intent
but I love that almost
everything here, these are,
sometimes they have documentary
elements or responding
to specific events in history and
time but they are poetic images.
They are artist responses.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
They are poetic images
and they are beautiful.
They take time to create and yet
they're looking out they want
to tell us something but
not necessarily for private.
Who knows?
Let's leave it open.
Are they private?
Are they public?
Are they both--
>> Katherine Blood: These are
meant to be in the street.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: These
are meant to be in the streets.
Now they are meant to be
out the streets again
throughout the United States.
>> Katherine Blood:
It belongs to every--
I mean we have been giving you
wonderful red carpet treatment
but this treatment is
available to anyone
who comes here as a researcher.
This collection belongs to everyone.
It belongs to you, to you,
it belongs to everyone.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Beautiful, beautiful, beautiful.
>> Katherine Blood: You have been
creating new artwork and new poetry
on the spot, right
here, automatic drawing.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Yes, I have.
>> Katherine Blood: Responding.
This one is called Give Power.
And --
>> Katherine Blood:
[Laughs] that was generous.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:[Laughs]
as a matter of fact,
I think that was your line.
Was that your line?
>> Katherine Blood: He asked me
to title it and of course I am
with a Poet Laureate of the
United States and I got nervous
and I didn't want to provide a title
and I said you are giving me a lot
of power and so you are like that's
what we are going to call it.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That's right.
>> Katherine Blood: Empowerment.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That's right.
We are not going to wait for to
write, we never wait to write.
Always write right
there at the moment.
If you wait to write,
something is going to happen.
As a matter of fact,
write before you write.
That's the idea.
So it's called Give Power and since
today is an anniversary of 9/11--
>> Katherine Blood: That's right.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: So here,
this a very, it's a drawing poem
and this is Give Power
and it is dedicated for
and then there is a
heart in a circle.
So, I am going to leave
that with you.
Perhaps it is dedicated
to love and to unity.
And it has images like this.
So page one and two is la luna, la
vida and the last page is estrellas.
The moon, life and the stars.
>> Katherine Blood: And these
are reoccurring motifs for you?
This is something you
carry with you, I think.
>>Juan Felipe Herrera: I
think you got me on that.
I think you got me on that.
And then there is kind of a light
gray marker with a moon and kind
of like the sea anemone
and an energy ring
and some waves and
some Mayan numbers.
And we made a book out of it.
>> Katherine Blood: Yes.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
We made a book out of it.
>> Katherine Blood: On the spot.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: On the spot.
>> Katherine Blood:
You did it today.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Did it today.
>> Katherine Blood: Very quickly
and directly from your conscious
and subconscious emotions.
It is wonderful and also poetry.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
And we did some poems too
and I am just going
to show them to you.
Here is a poem, it's called
Lantut [phonetic] 6 Green Method
and here's another one, it's
called Little Shoes on the Corner
and this has to do
with the prayer rug.
>> Katherine Blood: Right.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: It
has to do with a prayer rug.
>> Katherine Blood: Right.
The Helen [inaudible] drawing.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Yes.
Little Shoes on the Corner, the
beta carpet, are you waiting,
fly with rebirth, prayer; for us all
come together, but how, two, two,
two, two, two, two, two cultures,
banner, American, Arab how, how,
how, how the buildings come back
up as we stand, color to color,
Americas Middle East, together,
nontoxic, screen method.
>> Katherine Blood: So beautiful.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
So we can do this anytime
and what else do we have?
>> Katherine Blood: Let's
walk around the corner
to Julia de Burgos [phonetic] is one
of the heroes in your recent book.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Yes, we
are going to walk around the corner
and to Julia de Burgos,
Puerto Rican poet,
an amazing activist,
woman of her time.
And we also have it in a multicolor
format done by, who is it--
>> Katherine Blood:
Antonio Martorell
from Puerto Rico and
printed in Ponce.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Antonio
Martorell from Puerto Rico?
>> Katherine Blood: Brand
new acquisition, 2014.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: 2014?
>> Katherine Blood: This one is
2014 and it is again a combination
of digital and traditional
woodcut print making.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Digital,
traditional and then we have a lot
of material that we have
been just bringing out
and it is all available here.
We have Octavio Rodrigues
[phonetic] with [foreign word].
>> Katherine Blood: [Foreign
word] series which relates
to your book of [foreign
word] poems.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: That's
right and that's Octavio Rodriguez
and then we have Yolanda
Lopez and she's talking
about farm work of women and--
>> Katherine Blood:
Woman's work is never done.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Woman's work is never done
with Alordes Worta [phonetic].
>> Katherine Blood: Another hero.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Another hero
and then we have something
very magical.
A Russian--
>> Katherine Blood: Leanna Teescov
[phonetic] from Moscow and he,
this is from a series that he
conceives of as a visual poem.
It's called his private moon
series and you really --
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: I like that.
>> Katherine Blood: Sort of
went deep into these images.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: I like that
a lot because it is so dreamlike
and it is not, you know,
direct message piece.
It is something that you meditate
on and it is eerie and it is magical
and it is luminous and
it is multi layered
and with little poems
written on the side.
Little poems written on the
side of a beautiful print
and all this material
is just so inspiring.
And then we have this particular
artist that you mentioned to me--
>> Katherine Blood:
Robert Blackburn.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Robert Blackburn,
another amazing silk screen artist.
>> Katherine Blood: He is a
lithographer, color lithography
and that is what this is.
This is called Girl in Red
and it is from 1950 and one
of the wonderful things is that
it was on exhibit at the Library
of Congress in our 1897
Historic Jefferson Building.
We had national exhibitions
of prints for many years
and this work was hanging
at a Library of Congress
when it was fresh off
the press in 1950.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: In
1950, so see, that's beautiful.
I am really inspired by that piece.
It's beautiful.
>> Katherine Blood: Well
he was another person,
this Casa de Colores
idea was something
that he also took to heart.
He grew up during, he grew up
in the WPA Harlem Arts Center,
where he learned lithography first
as a very young, talented artist.
And then he worked
at a master printer
at a legendary print making studio
called ULAE with Rauschenberg,
Jasper, Johns, Frank and Faller.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That's amazing.
>> Katherine Blood: And he, in the
late 1940's, he made his own studio
which was open and his
concept was that it was open
to artists of all stripes.
And also of different
levels of abilities
so you have master artists
working with artists who are coming
to print making for the first time.
So, it was his own Casa de Colores,
the print making workshop
in New York.
You would have loved it.
You would still love
it, it still existed.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: I
would, I still love it and I am
so glad you taught me all about him.
And we also have Juan
Fuentes [foreign word] Chavez,
Juan Fuentes [inaudible]
Chavez, amazing print
and then we have [foreign
word] and Lydia Mendoza.
>> Katherine Blood:
You asked for music.
You asked for music, Tejano [assumed
spelling] music specifically, yea.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Tejana
music, pioneer from the 1920's,
Lydia Mendoza then
just kept on going.
And created so much great root music
or source music for the rest of us
that came along with guitars and
especially women song writers
and all the musical heritage that
we have for Latina's and Latino's
and of course, the public
at large, United States
and our truly American culture.
Beautiful print by [foreign
name] and it is also here
in it's beautiful, radiant colors.
>> Katherine Blood: You are
making a really wonderful point,
which is that all of
these connect to all
of the different artistic
languages so you can go
and listen to original music.
You can go and listen
to poetry readings
by poets across time, you know.
It goes on and on, this sort
of connections and layers.
Thank you for bringing
your artists by
and your poets voice
to these materials.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you, Katherine.
This is really beautiful.
I want to thank you
for inviting me over.
>> Katherine Blood: It's
an honor and a pleasure.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Thank you and for bringing
out these beautiful materials.
A family of great artists
for the people.
>> Katherine Blood: Yes.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And Casa
de Colores and [Foreign name]
and we are going to work
on something to feature
from this beautiful collection for
everyone to see online pretty soon.
>> Katherine Blood: Are
seed and flowers and plants.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Seeds and flowers and plants
and prints and photographs.
How's that?
>> Katherine Blood: Perfect.
Thank you.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Thank you so much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.